it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter in the kid
we're out come on baby yeah yeah you're
drinking your whiskey i'm drinking my
magic mine that's the difference between
us yeah now this is not a sponsor but in
case anybody's wondering but i'm rolling
on magic mine right now because sponsor
on cats after dark oh yeah you're
welcome oh that's right in the fridge oh
damn i know i'm stealing them i'm
stealing them i'm obsessed with daddy's
wide web this is kind of the only this
is a nootropic i guess it's is it
nootropic
yeah the guy who created it [ __ ] uh
am i gonna [ __ ] my pants no no no no no
no no
i don't know but the the guy who created
it had a heart thing he's made all the
money in the world it's the only reason
i know about it he wrote a book called
beyond coffee i'm like whatever i read
this thing
the [ __ ] dude's like just try it you
know you got sigmatic and mushrooms are
very powerful there's a blend of
mushrooms green tea and a bunch of other
[ __ ] that is so special
but i'm telling you dude i'm [ __ ] i'm
the guy who's like no look it's got it's
got matcha lion's mane all these [ __ ]
different mushrooms you know what but
there's been about two grams of sugar
though oh no
but there's been a lot of research into
it like nine years of research and i'm
i'll i'll go with anybody who's who
doesn't yeah it's nice right i'll go
with anybody who doesn't who's not
looking to make money on it who does it
as a philosophy yeah sure
it tastes like you put honey all over a
lawnmower and just lick the line
which i enjoy i do i do too uh nothing
that's that fresh [ __ ] green
antioxidant he's got this special you
know what you know what i'm obsessed
with i haven't had in forever so i'm not
that obsessed with so i'm just being
dramatic yeah but i love wheat grass
shots
see i that me too i used to drink that
[ __ ] all the time too yeah remember all
the kale shakes ice making spinach yes
that [ __ ] makes you feel good that's how
i feel about this it's just like
if it works it works like i was very
careful i was like i've tried a lot of
different [ __ ] and i just
i don't know i used to i used to
subscribe to this juice thing i think it
was like moon juice or whatever in
venice when i lived down oh yeah and
they would drop fresh juice off every
morning
there's a problem though dude you can
only drink someone's juice because you
can and then when they when they drop
four off a day eventually your
refrigerator is just
full of green juice yeah they can only
drink so many and they go when they go
bad when that wheat grass and kale goes
sour you go sour daddy yeah
i don't know if you should do that much
i was doing that for a long time i don't
know if anything like that you do that
much i think
meat and fruit i can do that [ __ ] all
day like a different fish meat all day
fruit yeah i just do red meat yeah
henry rollins just drinks carrot juice
that's it yeah that's weird i love
carrot juice that's fine a lot of sugar
in it i'm gonna need something i love
carrots i'm gonna eat protein
completely did i like a nice carrot
myself
i'm an oyster guy i told you i'm a
shellfish guy absolutely ever since i
read about what shellfish does dom
d'agostino i think he's this scientist
at college florida college of medicine
he was talking about how how much what
you get from one [ __ ] oyster it's a
it's a story i only like small oysters
me too i like them smaller like the
creamy small ones i don't want big flag
ones it feels like someone spit a loogie
no i will not eat those it's disgusting
i ate the kumamoto i eat anything from
the west coast it's small yeah the
kumamoto the small delicious and then i
dip it in vinegar oh dude i put vinegar
lemon i gotta push hot sauce i gotta put
your horseradish otherwise no bro those
big boys we gotta chew on no no thank
you dude it's like just something he's
just dude those big thick oysters it
just feels like someone just first of
all busted a load right in your mouth
yeah when you go to like chesapeake bay
and they're like we got these out of
maryland out of the harbor you can go
[ __ ] yourself i know those boats
live
slab of like
snot there you go with your shots and
people are like uh they oh my dad with
the juice [ __ ] off no my oysters have to
be tight clean small small you know what
we you know what we like and discipline
we like twinks
we like little twink oysters i want i
want you i like your big beard pearly
little back on them
a little round i want to see his tummy
no ugh i like my oysters like i like my
men small and bottoms you feel me the
bottom feeders small smooth small smooth
and plumpy yeah small no here smooth and
meaty yeah yeah no i don't like meaty
you like a little gymnast you're like a
little gymnast guy sure little little
strong
clean
you know what you like you like a
[ __ ] you like that skater who was
that skater we had a crush on for a long
time with a tail piece
olympic skater you and i what oh the
dude okay yeah ice skater oh ice skater
oh uh he was a cutie
with his hair all done up oh it's like
it was a puppet pop pippin something we
had the nicest ass on the planet
yeah he's a duck
that's no that's him up there in the
green far left second row yeah yeah damn
right it is dude you can pick him out
you picked him out
in a in a hot yeah dude my boy bro you
picked him out i don't want to rip it i
call him
that was a small picture you know my man
here's my boyfriend i know my man you
saw his outline i know my man he was
like that was like a jordan sneaker
outline you were like that's my
boyfriend spot that ass from a mile away
that's hilarious you refuse to meet with
mike pence
look at that ass dog
and he's he's a beautiful explosive
explosive yeah and disciplined
sure and this is what he does now but
yeah he's how i like my oysters
yeah you know as a skater you have
really one or two olympics at the most i
guess for sure you don't have a whole
lot else
he's a small guy is he a short it looks
like he's tiny a tiny fin there's this
man oh that's his man he's dating a big
old man
don't like this suit dude you speaking
of ice skaters i'm going to portland you
know who's from portland can you guess
the trailblazers
wait who's from portland
i see a hint
like famous ice skating oh greg lamont
no no no no because i'm not like we joke
about guys don't care about men ice
skating right because we don't care yeah
yeah so it's like women oh no apollo ono
that's another guy okay he's on my lady
yes because i don't care about male
skating because we just went over that
right okay because we joke about it but
honestly okay so wait there's a it's a
skater
ice skater okay and he's a he's a woman
she's a woman he's like you're older
here's the thing you're older you keep
saying skater and i'm thinking of nigel
houston right like a skateboard yeah
yeah say ice skating
i'm gonna rip your invisaligns out right
and i need some you do need some
ice skater ice skater female woman woman
very famous tara lipsky
nope michelle
oh no nope come on dude um i'd say the
most famous one
would also some would say the most
famous they would also
whoop your ass
beat me up had her own motion picture
well ice skater little white trash she's
some might say
and i knew her and i knew her
not nancy kerrigan but um the one who
beat her out yes but um and i i i had a
couple conversations with her tanya
harding tonya harding had a couple
conversations with her lives in oregon
hunts her own food she's from portland
in a cabin yep
and uh yeah she's a tough one she's a
tough one tough lady
we used to do world's dumbest together
so i would see her there and we'd talk
and stuff
how was she in person she she grew up a
rough lifestyle yeah she was her mom was
vile
started when she was four she was like a
savant ice skating yeah it was expensive
so the teacher funded it all was like oh
i got her she was she was she was a
defeated person at that point i think it
was very hard for her have you seen the
movie and i was like
fantastic i mean how long will pretend
that
hey
i know it's hollywood because you've
cast somebody else besides
[ __ ] margot robbie as time i got to
tell you she kind of pulled it off
she almost pulled it off who did marco
roberts no she could marco robbie can't
miss she did great but does she look
like tanya harden right there she looks
crazy but how long were pretending
no do me a favor go down the one where
they're side by side at the red carpet
okay
okay yeah well as well had a lizard play
tanya hardy you know what i'm saying
with makeup well
yeah tanya's older and and well michael
rob is the most beautiful woman in the
world i told you all in person know it
and also she's insanely talented that's
the other problem she's stupid oh yeah
those look exactly the same that's cool
it's tough though where do you go
hollywood it's tough you know alex is
the same way to go hollywood yeah but
she still pulled it off right
i mean i guess now now um tonya harding
did a boxing match with somebody and he
beat the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of that gal
and i could have told you how that was
going to go
she grew up rough dude like poor rough
that's right so if you're she fights
by men her dad her friend or her dad
left her but uh her all her boyfriends
that she had you know
now have you ever seen the 30 for 30
antonio heart on espn it will break your
heart i believe she grew up so rough i
believe it man
and then she and then you know i'm not
making fun of her but also like she
wasn't the prettiest girl right and then
figure skate that's why like nancy
kerrigan and these other girls like they
got all the promotion type of attention
tony harden did the first what it was at
3 6 or some [ __ ] like that and she's
like look at me dude like i know but
your face that is so [ __ ] true it's
not cool
and it starts also part of the business
it starts when you're a little girl
though it's it really does it starts you
know when you're not an attractive child
or let's just say men or women yes but
especially women right so especially
girls who are in that world where beauty
makeup hair your sky skater it's a hell
of a
you know it's very hard you're basically
a victoria's secret model on skates and
i think i think a lot of the judges are
looking at all of that stuff oh 100
same thing it's like american idol too
man you look and they're the most
talented person usually doesn't win it's
usually the the all-american like
country boy or country girl wins and
like hold up i know this person's
whatever 400 pounds that's the better
singer yes america's like yeah and also
america and i was like yeah but we can
make money off this one yeah like okay
well it's not a it's not a competition
then right no
and that's exactly what it is and it
must be [ __ ] hard
i'll tell you right now if i had a
little girl and i want a little girl so
bad and she came out with just a [ __ ]
beak
you'd have to do something like when
she's 18 like we can fake this we can
fix this you you leave it up to them oh
yeah you know she was like dab this beak
is causing so many issues yeah i'd like
we'll
stick a little bit off the top you know
what let's ask the doctor
two for one because daddy needs it too
let's go two for one because i can't
breathe and i'd like a little off the
top that's a little off the top you want
to see if that beverage
two for one your original nose yeah yeah
even smaller though you know yeah
well there are certain things that give
me regular girls have and don't have and
then i think beauty is a hard thing man
it's a that's the one thing i kind of
appreciate about the woke movement with
like fat acceptance take it easy now
shame take it easy now hey hey
hey hold on
no
i am not a friend of the woke movement
in a lot of ways because i think it's a
lie but
but i do think that like when you put
pressure
when it's acceptable to make fun of
somebody for being
not as pretty conventionally pretty it
[ __ ] their life up agree yeah they
should not be made fun of yeah now
should they have contracts at victoria's
secret
here's what i think about that
here's what i think
if the marketplace will buy
your product because you are advertising
to a certain segment of the population
that is overweight and if that's a good
business decision you guys go ahead if
si thinks that's a good idea go ahead
so how many how many magazines are you
selling i just want to know i bet not
many i bet you they sold more when they
had the dime like like [ __ ] uh tyra
banks on there in their primary or or as
you know we're talking about it and
we've been talking about it for a while
and it created that that means sells
magazines but also you look at
abercrombie who got you know destroyed
but when they started they'd even offer
bigger sizes no and they were the number
one company in america and then now
they're more awoke which they should be
because what they were doing was
horrible yep kind of funny but also
horrible and now that they're more awoke
you know they're not nowhere near what
their sales used to be uh i agree
i agree because let's be honest they're
selling a dream that's not possible well
the
the debate and i think it's not even a
debate
there is a standard of beauty that seems
to transcend culture and time in a lot
of ways like you know when you see an
impossibly beautiful woman okay
like jeff connolly when she was young uh
who who are you talking about the woman
you saw in person margot robbie or any
uh but there are some women like that
will knock your [ __ ] dick into the
dirt you see them and you just go
what the [ __ ] is going on i think it was
the girl who was in pearl harbor who'd
you see in person she's from oh uh kate
beckinsale when you see someone like
that bro i thought it was an angel i
know that i was at an oscar party i
thought it was an angel strolling
through the party i was like
drunk cindy crawford when she was
younger okay saw her in new york you can
forget it you i don't give a [ __ ] where
you're from everyone recognizes they go
i don't know africa i don't care where
you're at you go holy [ __ ] there there
was this ethiopian woman when i was in
saudi arabia i was a young the first
time i realized what true beauty was
this ethiopian woman in saudi arabia she
comes in
and she was friends with a woman who was
working there and she was even as young
when i looked at my mother i go mom
she's mommy what's going on here like i
couldn't
my mother said
i was
11 or 12. my mother said you didn't take
your eyes off her mommy no one could
yeah she's just i called my mom i caught
i still called him still called my man i
know it drives me nuts i call my mom i
don't i say big mike to my dad because i
can't call him daddy it's just way too
embarrassing yeah daddy's but i never
called my mom or dad i called him mommy
and daddy so all my girlfriends would
laugh so hard i'd be in college going
mommy can you tell me no i laughed too
because when i when i would come to your
sister's house when she had those
barbecues yeah she'd like
did you talk to mommy or daddy yeah no
she go mommy said i'm like hey you guys
are 50. quit saying that man yeah yeah
you know but mommy said that we should
get the casserole like whoa
so embarrassing that's kind of cute and
that's what i would do in public
my
mom
so mortifying but that's more
embarrassing to call her mom cause i've
never called her mom so i don't know how
to do it so now i call her i call him
big mike when my mommy my kids are young
so he call me daddy it's cute or they
call me papa which is super cute when
they say daddy you know they're young so
it's good yeah when they're about 10 or
12 they quit with the daddy my kids call
me dad that's it dad my daughter calls
me father when she's being cheeky father
in public father
father like all right
but um it's fun and you know i grew up
with i don't know how you do it i grew
up with
you know my p
my mom's side's from england so i
basically they're like the [ __ ]
osbornes they cussed nonstop i grew up
around working class english yeah
smoking cussing it's just what we did
drinking yeah everyone had a nickname
like joking clown each other i always
forget that you're actually english your
mother is actually english yeah yeah her
sisters have accents dude yeah yeah so
i grew up with that culture like cussing
not so cussing really didn't have power
you know what i'm saying like it wasn't
like a forbidden thing so i didn't
really cuss like sometimes i went around
my friends but i knew not to do around
my teachers so even with my kids same
philosophy i mean we're not cussing up a
storm like i grew up with but
you know tiger knows not to do it around
his teachers he'll do it around his
friends maybe i assume but like we draw
on sunday we're driving to uh
to the car show we go every sunday and
on the bronco the the chair that because
it's a two-seater so i gotta
pull the chair back so he can jump out
and we get there i'm trying to pull the
chair back and i can't get it so then i
i go over to grab boston like t just
come out this side and he's like no i
got it and he's getting it he must heard
me say like whatever two sundays ago
it's crazy how they remember [ __ ] and
he's doing it won't work he goes this
piece of [ __ ] i'm like
oh
bubba
whoa bubba piece of [ __ ] this is a
bronco dude and then he goes it's a four
dad i'm like you heard me say that
ford's are cool man you're getting all
this from me my son did that to his
sister my son was just [ __ ] seven and
she was just kept bugging me shut the
[ __ ] up
it's hilarious
especially with their timing it's
hilarious room like us i know piece of
[ __ ] oh my gosh whoa dude and he said
exactly how i did i'm like whoa dude
i like come on i guess it's not a piece
of [ __ ] it's a ford
hey dude
well be cool man because oh you have no
he doesn't know you know he knows he
doesn't know difference between real he
knows cars but like to him like cars are
cars he doesn't know money and so lambo
ford it's all the same to him
lamborghini forward ferrari but he's
like it's a four damn like dude
i said that the other day because
someone said how's this drive i go it's
a fort yeah you know yeah so he's just
picking up all my stuff but he doesn't
know the context
it's so funny it's so great it's so cute
when they do it so [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
how old are your boys five now six yeah
bossy's two it's such a good age
yeah man yeah you're yeah your mom comes
from that that english working class
that that that's almost like the tyson
fury it's like that's a rough area she
from manchester was she from the north
no no it'd be the south so stroud so
it's like an hour
uh south from london okay like yeah
working class small well those working
class towns and you go up to you know
the the north of england the
tough people i mean they smoked like
chimneys the [ __ ] dude my grandpa had
lung cancer from smoking they said if
you keep smoking it's going to cut
this cancer you're going to die
eventually that's like yeah whatever bro
he had an oxygen tank
would take it off smoke and then they
told my girl yes stop smoking too get
sick and i smoked chimney in there i
grew up just chimney chimney yeah yeah
they loved it man it's just what they
did
yeah
i mean you watch like the royals it's
like everyone's back everybody smokes
that's what the [ __ ] they did yes they
didn't realize you know well they did
but it's like they did they but they
didn't yeah you know what i'm saying
like they didn't realize
the irish i mean the the smoking and the
whiskey
the the hard alcohol it's not like
mediterranean wine it's like i'm gonna
[ __ ] winston churchill who lived
until he was 91 always had a cigar in
his mouth and
historians said he probably always had
some alcohol in his system always beast
i've been around those brits where
they'll they'll like they'll be like
slow gin
it's 8 a.m just we're going hunting we
got to do a shot of slow gin and then
they just it just keeps
you know i don't i don't have that i
don't have that chemistry no i can't do
it you can do it oh yeah you can do it
and you'd be fine if i drink i'm
drinking right now i couldn't wait to
get studio to drink yeah well no you're
not a problem that's okay yeah and but
you're a functioning alcoholic and 100
percent high functioning alcoholic yeah
it did work out though before you drink
i did work out and my back is super
toasty because me and mark didn't have a
lot of time so i just set the timer for
10 minutes and we'll just do 60 sets of
315. like 60 reps yeah so
i go six he goes six so we're gonna do
16.
no deadlift 315.
which is like that's like you know and
you didn't really have time to warm up
we didn't warm up at all first that was
3 15.
yeah it's i mean it gets your heart rate
up and yes you're like by the end of it
you're going to really be feeling it
it's good when you're short on 3 15 is
nothing for you guys i mean it's live
towards the end i got left i first said
you're like this is easy tenth set
you're like oh my body once you're
halfway like 10. you can really get like
10 seconds you get like 35 seconds rest
if you're going on the minute yeah we're
going off i would say as you're working
you get about 30 seconds of rest yeah so
think about it jesus christ ten sets of
six with 30 seconds very hard
you're sweating are you uh is that it
for you today that's all you'll do i
worked out at six i did chess this
morning with uh a client of mine do you
think you're better than me mark no take
it easy yeah i think you're [ __ ] cool
damn take it easy dude it's all right
dude it's all right
i wasn't happy about it waking up
[ __ ] better than me like would you
get up at five he's a trainer he's a
trainer yes
um
so no i mean i'd like
you couldn't be happier with your tits
right now and you're like i'm happy the
result like yes what it does do is like
if i keep doing that i hate it what i'm
doing is like um oh my god i want to
sleep in two more hours but then like at
the end
i'm so busy and i'd be like you almost
forget that you did it yeah you know
what i mean and you're like oh right i'm
still in shape even though i felt
stressed out yeah get out barely's over
eight and the key to everything yes key
to everything mark look at my now i'm a
coat hanger yeah i'm not a natural
mesomorph the way you guys are a couple
mesomorphs in history i'm an ectomorph
couple mesomorphs okay
um just naturally i'm not an endomorph
no i use i feel like an ass you're built
like an ant i built like well i got my
leg i got the legs of a frog got a bit
of a booty on me we're doing all right
there no you're built like the wb frog
okay
that's probably true bring that up
gently just don't have the natural hard
for me to put on muscle yeah you got a
year you got a year yeah you can do
whatever you want to me uh-huh you can
i'll i'll take whatever you put it's
brian's body right there but but is the
is there objective aesthetics do you
just want to look at that that's all we
want okay that's all we want i'm not you
want me to take you from here mark
steroids yeah
steroids your age no i know that we know
we have to do that there's not a train
on this earth who's going to put muscle
i work out every day but that nothing's
going to look exactly the same yeah
depending on what side effects you'd
want to avoid um i don't want to die and
i don't know
you can take so many steroids before you
die it's insane yeah like people have
this notion of like well i'd like to i'd
like to not have it impact my longevity
ultimately okay well there's still a lot
you can take because i like his face get
a little bloated just for my own sake i
just throw the water retention
is all about like what side effects do
you want to avoid i'm using even more
hair right okay if you want to say [ __ ]
that's like one right you go do you want
to [ __ ] the hair or not you know what i
mean because because things like taking
for example an androlone only cycle is
one of the most hair safe things you can
do the conventional wisdom is you don't
take nandrolling without testosterone
because you needed to convert to you
know there's this science and theory
behind it but turns out there are
certain more safe like hair-safe
steroids than even testosterone you can
take testosterone and take finasteride
with it which blocks the dna conversion
you can so there's many things you can
take to mitigate my loss
or just say [ __ ] all that noise and get
a wig
when you talk about that no but if
you're going steroids you don't have to
worry about the hair yeah i'm never
wearing a [ __ ] wig yeah you're in my
mouth just just as far as training the
hacks that i would recommend to guys um
to most guys if you build up your your
shoulders to an insane degree and like
kind of your upper back and upper chest
yeah those are the things
when you look at the silhouette yeah you
go you want to have wide lats broad
shoulders and big upper chest so i do
like high incline
stuff for
yeah like because most guys
most guys do on a regular incline you're
still not quite hitting this like real
upper fiber that connects to your
shoulders
lateral raises all the time so you're
building up this part because that's
what like makes you even two inches this
way think about how dramatic that was
pretty dramatic you know yeah and you
could put two inches on my shoulder
absolutely yeah and then like as you as
you if you think about this if you put
it i'm not [ __ ] talking to you i'm
more of a real take a little bit of fat
off your stomach and add it a little bit
to your it's like for every inch wider
you get
and yeah
but i actually want to look um i don't
care about that v i want to look thicker
i want to just look okay so if you want
it to look thick you're talking about
gold's gym stack here
jack uh winston oh yeah you could take
like the upper limit of what you could
do as far as deca and still be safe
because it's like look we've talked
about like trend and stuff like that
it's just that i took a bunch of trend
not too long ago and the real effect is
like you can't work out as hard you're
almost getting like sick because of the
cardiovascular effects you know i was
taking 100 milligrams of trend a day
just i talked about this in my podcast
as like an experiment and
like you get bigger and stronger really
quickly but you're like in the gym like
oh i feel like [ __ ] like if we did those
dead lifts today like i would have been
like
oh my god like you almost get ill
all right
so i don't want any of that [ __ ] right
because it increases your blood pressure
i got a year give me the [ __ ]
cocktail yeah give me the time here's
what we can do for you what nothing no
no no come on test honestly this the
most old-school cycle you can do is
almost test deck a d-ball
what's d-ball diana ball
that's great it's for like it's a very
mild side effect it a little less hair
safe but it's a cosmetic effect like
think zac efron and baywatch people look
at him and go like he's on anavar if
you're really lean it makes you look
harder and kind of like not brad pitt
and fight club that's like the anavar
winstrol look it is if you were to take
something like that yeah that was what i
was sponsored by
he's 147 pounds in there come on yeah he
talks about it he's there there's
steroids like edward norton
halo test and animals
yeah because everyone like i was reading
this thing on bodybuilding.com was a
huge fan of bodybuilding.com back in the
day and they're like everyone goes i
want to look like brad pitt from fight
club and then brad pitt came out in
interviews he's like dude i was like
starving myself i was 147 something
pounds yeah the real thing i see is just
a he's extremely lean in his way he's
looking [ __ ] troy and he has very
broad shoulders look at troy you know
and troy he looks like he gained at
least 15 pounds
now that that's not natty no no no you
would assume that because that's his
baseline you've got to realize like brad
pitt is not a naturally big guy
like when you see
louise he is so skinny right so that's
what that would and a lot of actors are
like that where like he's he's his face
almost looks like he'd have a bigger
body and then he's really thin yeah so
for a guy who's very naturally thinned
up to look like he doesn't troy dude his
body won't quit and uh
and um
uh once once upon a time in hollywood
his body's body for days yeah yeah so
you see how
like clean naturally ectomorphic yeah um
i'm i'm into it man that's that's my
body i'm an actor
but if you just wanted to put a muscle
there's some you don't look like him
high dose when i was younger i had that
body and dianaball is actually the
muscular in the arms the american
response to tariniball which was the
ussr steroid the only stereo that was
made without a pharmaceutical purpose
like is everything else like antivirus
for muscle wasting or whatever if you
have aids
they're like trying to balls like the
only thing that was produced in mass by
like you know a sort of like government
or like the the medical industry in that
country but it was just for performance
enhancement so all these like the east
germans and the russians tariniball hey
mark diana baldwin turned to steroids
huh well they make they make it you
better understand i've been a steroid
geek since like the late 90s maybe let's
take a little break from we're some
chatty kathy's today dude now where can
i ask you a question i'm busy and i like
to eat my meat but i sometimes just
cooking vegetables doing vegetables and
like getting my phytonutrients yeah you
gotta have probiotics you gotta multiple
vitamins i don't wanna do that is there
anything you wanna say well i'm not
doing it in portland next week oh you're
not doing anything i mean donuts at
voodoos because i'm on tour in portland
oregon next week that's next thursday
friday saturday exciting portland
healing portland's going to be come get
something
that's that's next thursday friday
saturday in portland oregon this
thursday this friday saturday i'm in
richmond virginia that's right dude
virginia next friday saturday i'm in
omaha nebraska at the funny bone june
10th and 11th yeah where are you so i go
portland next week that is uh june 9th
through the 11th i'm in portland at the
helium and then after that the week
after i'm in san francisco at the cobb's
comedy club friday saturday only and
after that fort wayne indiana july 14th
16th great club and then i end the
well still part of the summer trash
panda tour whole new hour uh july 21st
through the 23rd san diego baltimore
august 4th through the 6th but portland
you're up next week but b
one thing you will have on the road with
me is my greens you gotta have your
greens gotta have your greens so wait
you're talking about you you pack a
bunch of celery and spinach and just
just have a bushel of green no bro dude
i have a pack a one little scoop of ag-1
by athletic greens all right dude you're
talking about all the daily nutrition
you need well it's super foods
dude it contains 75 vitamins minerals
whole food source ingredients include a
multivitamin multi-mineral probiotics
green superfood blend it's delicious bio
available it's easier on your stomach
you take a bunch of pills sometimes it
can really mess with rarely mess you up
man
do join the movement of athletes moms
podcasters comics rookies first timers
aunts uncles grandmas stepmoms whoever
you want the whole world to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you
immune supporting free one year supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
because you can't get in the sun all the
time oh dude with your first purchase if
you visit athleticgreens.com fighter
today again go to athleticgreens.com
fighter to take control of your health
and give ag-1 a try
you know i like my kicks dog yeah but
how do you keep them dude i'm glad i'm
how do you keep them clean because i'm
always scuffing my shoes bro i worked
out on these today
look like i'm working on corn did a
unicorn poo those out dude how do you
keep them so shiny and beautiful i'm so
glad you asked i use rejuvenator that's
rejuvenator dude oh they have over 2
million satisfied customers a 4.5 star
average reviews dude reshuvenator offers
a variety of cleaning products to keep
your kicks clean man all the kicks you
see i post every day uh thick boy studio
kicks every single day they're looking
fresh they're the only youtube channel
is it youtube dot com slash reshuv
enable re shoe
vn eight the number eight r yeah
dude if you or someone you know
appreciates a nice clean kick
reshuvenator is a must-have for a
limited time reshuvenator is offering
you guys the final kid army
all you guys you get 15 off the most
effective shoe care line available all
you need to do is visit reshuvenator.com
fighter and you will save right at
checkout 15 that is r e s h o e v n
eight r dot com slash fighter fifty
percent off reshuvenator.com
fighter so impressive because i thought
you were 100 natural a lot of people do
yeah mark you should write a book
steroids for dummies yeah and that'd be
sick huh yeah yeah i don't think they
have that stereotype like when i was a
kid it was like just hearsay and then
bodybuilding then bodybuilding.com no
when then bodybuilding.com popped up and
there was actual guys like running
cycles but they were so
over the top you're like i'm not doing
all that [ __ ] but now there's so much
like information on steroids if you
really want to do it yeah there's actual
information like plates more dates do to
help you out what's his name for the
average guy uh derrick for more play
sports yeah he's great he knows him on
the show huh he knows
oh yeah and from a chemistry wicked i've
had people tell me that more plates
what's it yeah
some more dates he's super smart yeah
i've heard that i've heard people have
said to me that that guy knows his [ __ ]
is he a doctor i would say and these
three guys have a podcast together they
do sometimes vigorous steve leon
longevity and uh more plates more dates
it's six hours long though yeah correct
too long though fellas you know this
right i'm saying if you i like it you
want to hit the trifecta of like
peds any sort of hair stuff any sort of
like biohacking which leo and longevity
specializes in and he's a fan of youtube
guys i want to connect get him on the
podcast oh dude he he's he's here oh
yeah no he has like
his level of self-taught information all
of them but like leo like yeah like with
like nicotine like he'll like drop these
videos on like the cholinergic system
it's like you're a professional you feel
like you're getting a lecture from a
robot
if you can get information it's from him
they know more than doctors because they
go down that correct and right
on themselves too like they're brilliant
well they said that they said that
like bodybuilders like the bodybuilder
community they were the ones who came up
with a lot of the um uh and also the
russian sports community they came up
with a lot of like
nutrition glycemic
and they know index
about everyone but this certain
percentage it's like you meet somebody
they're very smart you're just muscular
they're chemists basically
there's some of them but then there's
some of them that they're running so
much gear like if you watch the ronnie
coleman documentary he doesn't know what
he's doing yeah he's like he's eating
chicken and he's like you know i like to
eat lean here but he's putting so much
barbecue sauce on you're like dude
that's a hundred grams of sugar yeah but
he's running so much gear it doesn't
matter and his body's just when he was
natural and claims to be like i believe
it like
just the most insane genetics you've
ever yeah hey can you because he was a
cop right in texas can you imagine
getting pulled over for running from
ronnie coleman as a cop and his outfit
he looked ridiculous right
and you have steroids he's like i don't
have to put you away
are you
[ __ ] me are you [ __ ] me dude
look at it you're running the same [ __ ]
imagine him pulling you over
he's so awesome have you guys ever
discussed that chef the white house chef
with the big arms who's about that size
and he goes like i'm all natty there's a
white house chef this size and he said i
mean yes look him up by shout out to how
much i think his name is he looks
imagine him pulled over by him for
substance like steroids yeah and he's
gonna have to put you in a slammer
andrew andre rush yeah i love these guys
um and he's so i mean his arms look like
25 inches legit like what's he make um
and that guy says i'm all natural he's
awesome
yeah okay
is it is that possible that he could be
all natural it's to be fair i know i
know guys like tim tebow like joe
kloffenstein yeah i'm telling you dude
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] freaks freaks some
guys yeah like specifically with the
arms his arms are so big but like
some guys he's not like lean from
certain parts of the world have really
big arms and uh like look at look at
francis cingado right like just jack to
the gills if i had to guess though i
would say he look at alistair old
yeah but hey let's not wear that watch
though huh right i don't mind it i'm not
afraid of it
so
he has an incentive like he's a public
figure going like i don't want to like
if it gets out you know what i mean you
always go what's their incentive to lie
these days you have an incentive to like
be open and you could start a youtube
channel and give information
back in the day they'd be like hey
you're pushing our creatine don't say
anything about students
and you had to like lie about it i loved
you right away because and i remember
brendan told the story about you he was
like he was like some guy said was
making fun of your technique or your and
something and you were like and you're
like hey and you said hey from one juice
head to another yeah that's a weird
weird flex
it really takes some of that angle that
people love to do they it's like one of
the primary things
it's like yeah i am would you want are
you not always going to be on it do you
think um at least a maintenance dose of
testosterone like a which i would
consider like a hundred to two hundred
milligrams there's no growing back from
mark and um now you could like you could
do hc like it's just but why would you
want to testosterone is one of these
safest things you can put in your body
yeah you know i gotta get i gotta get
busy with you you're never doing it but
chin chin i have faith chin i think is
gonna do it i'm already like in the
process of trying to do it
i think i think it would be awesome
like when you say for example when i
think about you performing i go like
does this person want to add 10 pounds
of muscle and like and recalibrate like
how their body moves on stage that's
always for me that do i have a question
if i were you
because i personally think it's like oh
do i want more energy and feel better if
you don't that's fine yeah i feel no you
don't i know but imagine you felt even
better
i don't know i don't know
i get we go back to me worrying about
i've been given this gift of energy
right i've been giving this gift yeah
you're peter pan you know what i mean
and i just slowing down a little bit
though yeah a little bit huh a little
bit a little bit i get tired now i know
i was on stage for you know
seven hours yeah and i and i'm just a
little tired after that i work out now
imagine if you weren't tired but you're
also like grabbing pythons and [ __ ] you
know if daddy gets eight and a half
hours of sleep eight hours of sleep i'm
[ __ ]
good i know but now imagine if you're
better yeah
and you got a proportion as a big thing
too because it's like going like oh this
person drinks and this person drinks
well that person has a couple shots
every saturday night and this person
has 15 beers a day because they're not
awesome yeah i don't drink well i think
much right this is a reference yeah i'm
just making an analogy though to going
150 milligrams of test per week versus a
and that is great for longevity it's
like yeah man you got that working for
you because like oh there you go oh
literal bry yeah the thing about me mark
is you know i have a glass of wine but
not full you know when i drink wine
mark's like no it's just using a
reference
but that is good because yes that would
it could disturb your natural test if
you were drinking alcohol i'm just
saying proportionally
when you see a pro bodybuilder on stage
you so you're taking trt 150 milligrams
a week
he's starting with 3 000 milligrams of
one ester of test and then adding test
suspension on that probably another
thousand milligrams a week and then
taking master on an echo those guys
aren't the pinnacle of health everyone
thinks they are their bodies
it is but it's like it's like a [ __ ]
pebble versus a boulder you know of
course do you ever have that with your
girl you're gonna fight she's been
saying because like
if it was you and me
tiger has his uh kindergarten graduation
on friday so he needs an outfit so i
i had an idea what i want him to wear i
wanted this little button up this
shirt's you know he's [ __ ] sick he's
a big six show but the shirts is [ __ ]
big yeah so it's in the bag and late at
night uh you know i see it on the
counter i'm like oh get it out
and i'm like i think this looks sweet
she goes
she bought it that day she and i go i i
take it out and soft i'm like i think
this is like sweet and she's like
where'd you get that where'd you buy
that i'm like
what
she's like that's yours i'm all
no it's not mine no it's not it's tigers
right because you bought it yeah today
it's for a six year old yeah look at the
size that she does you're an [ __ ]
but it's this big right i know
so it's so triggering to me i go well
well no it's not but you know and i'll
go you know it's not mine right because
let me hold this shirt up because you
could see it right like this for a
six-year-old yeah i'm 240 something
pounds i'm not gonna wear this yeah i
got called an [ __ ]
oh you called them
because twice a week because i was
because it's the same thing
what's the way we talk to each other
yeah like if i came in here with my son
shu and you went oh man that's your shoe
i'd go
excuse me yeah well no it's not my shoe
brian yeah this is for a six-year-old
right you know that right and then like
we joke about and you're like oh well
yeah women don't jump well and they
don't joke like that and also sometimes
as a man you're not communicating with
them so what happens is i will be in a
position where i'm putting out some
fires that are in i need to it's money
if it's money business whatever i'm
putting out focused on that i got some
[ __ ] i got to do right because otherwise
we have rent we have a lot of things i'm
a fireman i wake up in the morning i put
out 10 fires before i see you thank you
business yeah try that environment
fireman so you're doing this stuff that
seems to be very important to bottom
line stuff
and because i'm not communicating i'm
keeping it all inside she's not really
she doesn't know where the [ __ ] i'm
coming from so she comes in talking
about daisies she's talking about
something that i need i need to take
care of
and i go and then what happens is
because i'm
i'm preoccupied sure what i would do to
you is i'd go i don't give a [ __ ] about
that right i understand
noted right that's it there's no big
deal i go i don't give up i don't i oh i
do not give a [ __ ] about that but in my
head i'd be like oh he's probably
dealing with something all good i'll
come back later women or you wouldn't
even think that or you'd be like oh yeah
that makes
sense yeah or just what you did just now
go but he's making a reference like
that's hilarious to me you do that when
i so what i'll do is i'll go up just i'm
just being a moon and i go oh i don't
give a [ __ ] about that i could care less
i don't care about that i care about
that as much as
that bird
i'm a dick
and she's right
like like when i came home the baby had
pooed through his diaper yeah sure and
it was all out it was it was a blowout
it was on the comforter now the comfort
is not expensive it's not a down
comforter it's [ __ ] synthetic don't
give up she's done
[ __ ] she's busy as [ __ ] she's doing a
million things yeah she's also got the
kid that kid is young and it's all she's
got on her teeth
so
she kind of left it and what i do is i
go she left the poo poo she left the poo
poo and i like how long but you left it
to soak for how long though it was
probably an hour
i have a problem with that
yeah so i go it's gonna soak through
yeah and it's [ __ ] though right i go
well it's [ __ ] isn't it it's poo poo
right that's the car so it's the worst
smell in the world and it's in our
[ __ ] house right what she was doing
is she was going first of all i'll throw
that [ __ ] thing away
it's not a big deal because i got 15
other things she was doing which she was
and
she knew
that she can get that out i didn't
so what i do is i go this makes no sense
this i'm now i'm i'm griping no trigger
as i'm cleaning off
yeah and i'm going crazy but that caused
a problem these are relationship
dynamics well the problem is because we
talk so much for a living on podcasts
it's like over the top exaggerating we
have a certain dialogue the way we speak
yeah rough or rough we're rough we make
fun of each other it's whatever people
like oh you're bullying and it's like
have you not listened to the past 10
years that's how we talk that's what we
talk about yeah that's what we do
promise is when you keep that same
vocabulary with people that aren't in
the game like in your regular life
like if i talk to my agent the way i
talk to you or mark i don't know if you
remember missions when rogan we were
doing rogan a long time ago like this is
like eight years ago
and you were kind of vulnerable on your
own rogan it's a big podcast and you
were like no i have body dysmorphia
because i was a fat kid and so now when
i take my shirt off and i go like you're
trying to open up and i interrupt you
and i go but well let's get over that
right now huh cause that was in high
school yeah and you're a [ __ ] yeah yeah
and we're all laughing rogan starts
laughing and you're like but you were
kind of like no but you were trying to
yeah i kind of dunked water trying to
double down on it
you know that's how we do it yeah and
you can't do that to people who are
sensing in the real world no not to your
spouse not to your lady no no no no no
that joking does not flop the biggest
problem in my relationship the way i
talk yeah yeah my one tabula it's like
yeah my one buddy's from new york he's
made a billion dollars and i i i called
him up and i was on facetime and my girl
was there and he goes what's up [ __ ]
and she was like jesus and i was like no
that's that that's kind of establishing
the groundwork he's joking around we're
[ __ ] with each other yeah i don't
know that's where i draw the line
like if i called my buddy he looked at
my girl what's up [ __ ] i'm like
so next time i see you i'ma slap you
right like you know that i know he goes
in the car
oh he's calling you a [ __ ] yeah no not
her oh i thought he was saying he saw
her was like what's up [ __ ] no oh okay
no face time here oh with you [ __ ] oh
gotcha yeah yeah different yeah yeah
i thought
yeah it's not good it's great that's a
problem
you just can't you just can't it's just
a way of communicating something it's a
problem women don't relate to each other
with the humor men do a lot of times how
about ricky gervais i watched that
special how funny is that i was laughing
so hard he goes i'm not talking about
the old-fashioned
women with a womb i'm talking about the
new women with a beard and a [ __ ] he's
so funny
he's such a savage oh my god he's so
brilliant i was laughing so hard man
he's so brilliant like there's a comic
and you watch that and you're like oh i
got work oh he's so so inspired dude i
was like this [ __ ] the first
time i've like laugh out loud
like i'm talking how [ __ ] loud we
watched me and my girl a couple friend
of ours we were all howling and his
thing on transgender and like the
women's stuff
to me and it's this isn't a knock on
dave chappelle who's one of the goats
but it's his approach to it is so it's
weird his delivery it's less harsh and
less yes uh
do you know what i'm saying it's like i
watched them like i thought about that
and i'm like oh it's so smart that makes
it is so smart yeah ricky is just dave
chappelle's is smart and there's like a
he he goes a roundabout way of doing it
because the end he's trying to be like
it's empowering my best friends is
transgender like oh that makes sense all
that [ __ ] said [ __ ] ricky's like [ __ ]
off this high field but it's also so
creative and thoughtful the way he gets
i'm so clean
ricky gervais wrote him we
he's oh by the way you know he's a
high-level musician right no monster
yeah monster and i love how he was like
he took i think he he's like music by
ricky to race i don't think there was
any music in it
you don't you know my only complaint
it's this thing it's the only thing i'm
like i was gonna do that the the ted
talk yeah microphone yeah that's because
we're comics that's cause oh my god how
do you not want that mic i don't like
wireless mics anymore no i know i need a
cord dude yeah i know i need i have to
have a i ask all the time chord or
cordless i'm like quarter we always have
a cordless as issues sometimes it sounds
up sometimes
you can actually turn it off like i need
that cord yeah i like the the the
[ __ ] rope i like moving around it
right now i'm you know after the special
i got to come up with a whole new act
but i'm so inspired i watched something
like richard bason i'm just like boom i
start thinking
you know oh he was so [ __ ] good he's
so funny dude
well it also goes to show you that the
culture's changing
that we're fed up everybody's fed up
everybody's fed up with being bullied on
how to think you know there are these
comics i don't know if you know that
where they're signing these declarations
of never never telling never punching
down with their jokes like punching down
meaning people are not funny meaning
what like making no people oh nobody
good's doing that but but nobody making
money
no no the [ __ ] out that gives those
shitty comics like that they're not
coming well it gives them an agenda
right it's like oh i'm gonna be part of
this group it's like have you seen these
all of you are gonna make twelve dollars
a year tournament but they're not funny
no you've seen it but that's why they're
doing it oh it's hilarious successful
comics aren't
think about this you have to write a new
hour you don't have time to fight that
or do this sign a potential point
accommodation disturbs shakes you up and
you're like oh [ __ ] that that's the
whole point they're not funny the whole
the whole
far left awoke movement is the last two
things
sex and humor
and money and money sex humor and money
yeah yeah that makes the world and and
that makes the world go around and
muscle and and and and attractiveness
and attractiveness i'm sorry those four
things proportions they make the world
go attract
sir athleticism
sex humor money
and
just courage humanity encourage courage
so that makes the world go around the
world so how's that going for you and
also those things you listed off
that works for every society in the
world correct everyone go do your weird
alt comedy or your weird work comedy in
china i mean it goes for you
because you and i can go tour with the
troops do it anywhere in the world and
at the heart of it also you know
like it's critical right it's it's it's
it's
massively critical and
destructive and one of the things about
being a critic which we all are it's fun
to be a critic and one of the things
that i know for sure is if you spend
your life as a critic if you spend your
life looking at what's wrong if you
spend your life highlighting what's
wrong if you spend your life voicing
what's wrong all the time
that same critic
is you never escape it that same critic
i promise will come back and haunt you
when you try something so it actually
paralyzes you so if you don't find the
good and praise the good you don't get
anything done yeah but again no nobody
worth anything in this game is
podcasting or like have we ever
criticized somebody well i'll make some
jokes about a famous celebrity sure but
if it's somebody i know or somebody in
our world yeah have you ever heard me
criticize have you ever taken to
someone's instagram and been like you
suck have you ever done that i mean i
don't know i don't have time i don't
know you know what i wish i did it's not
you know yeah but that that kind of
stuff is uh very bad for the person
doing it
yeah but but also the the people doing
that they're not com they're they're
just not talented they're already but
they're also not they're talented
destroyed it's not talent it's
if you have talent you don't have time
to do that they're not doing well
no no no so that's that's why it goes
for him you know that's the thing about
people who rail against existence in
general it's [ __ ] a tough way to live
man it's not it must be exhausting being
that upset all the time and then to go
to twitter to express your concern what
was that thing too like confucius said
before you seek revenge remember to dig
two graves
one for yourself one for
you are spending all your time trying to
do old confucius
my therapist is brilliant and uh she'll
reference these old guys and like you
know confucius or whatever
emerson all this stuff and i have to
pretend i know what she's talking about
i'm like that's a good one
never heard of it before and should she
she's so smart she'll go write that down
because she'll know she should be right
there write that down she knows you're
not reading ralph waldo new missed that
and that's pretty cool that she does
that oh dude some of the somebody i'm
like i'm a therapist yeah you mentioned
that the other day yeah twice uh once a
week sometimes twice a week how long
have you been doing it um
almost six months now it helps you yeah
yeah it helps i never would have pegged
you for therapy me neither what got you
into it
uh i think when i started think boy just
the anxiety and stress that came with
like being responsible for employees and
then also having kids like things i have
with kids and with this mass shootings
and all the fears of having being a dad
and then you know you're talking about
money and just like they
seen it tough two years listen bubba i
didn't have anxiety when i was a top 10
heavyweight in the world fighting grown
men inside the octagon
i didn't have anxiety when i played in
huge
ball games for
university of colorado i don't have the
game plan i don't have anxiety being the
wedge buster against ct going against a
guy who's going to get drafted in the
first round
none of that gave me anxiety i know are
you never anxious never i do well with
it in fact i always i pride myself yeah
i pride myself you were like tough
always and i still am and i do a good
job at navigating through it but then
you guys know but then there's it keeps
chipping away keeps chipping away keeps
chipping away and then finally i'm like
oh i need some help yeah and i'm not
going to get help from it's not that i
can't talk to you or you know todd
feldman or rogan or the
that's great you need someone with an
ombudsman and also they're not in the
business
you know and so so she'll say things
like i'll tell and she's like and why
are you giving this energy i'm like well
because she goes i'm actually again
why are you like your energy is so
sacred man why are you giving that
energy i'm like i'm like as i said out
loud i'm embarrassed she's like you
should be yeah and then she should draw
like this stuff and then
the thing that we have too is i'll have
a lot of problems in any relationship
not just with my wife just in general
business whatever
in tax and email i can be very harsh
it's very black and white there's no
context
so she was like uh can i see you because
apparently you know your communication
there's something going on here she goes
can i go through your phone read through
your text oh absolutely she goes through
and i go this one was the problem and
she was really let me look at it and she
works with the other client she's
looking at she goes there's no contacts
there she goes in person
you're the nicest most thoughtful
biggest heart person i
one of the biggest people i've ever met
i would agree with that yeah she goes
but this doesn't there's no context so
this comes off you and i have done that
she knows this comes off like your steve
you and i'll start with she goes this
comes off like your steve jobs dude i
was like i know she goes
unless it's like reservations or hey
running ten minutes late no more texting
if it's important and it's meaningful or
it's business you have to get a point
across you're going to start calling
from now on
well you know who i thought of picked up
the phone you know i thought of joey
diaz
you ever text joey
he calls it every time he calls yeah
everybody joey detects hey what's up
brother just you know i'll catch up with
people through text just i'll think of
someone or someone i know is going
through a tough time or maybe they
dropped a special that they had a kid
i'll shoot a text you know it's like oh
thanks dude joe ebb i can't just check
in brother miss you
boom what's up [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] what's up dude one of the
things i'm writing about and thinking
about a lot at my age is that i'm
starting to realize that number one you
can't
you can't uh
you can't build enough armor
for
all the things that can [ __ ] you up
because there's there's variables there
are variables there's not the the armor
you're not aware of yet that's right but
you're going to build that armor when it
comes and there are enemies
that there are things that can get to
you that you ha you don't even know how
to fight back on that's kind of the
nature of life and the other thing is as
you get older
i i realize i don't know i don't have an
answer for a lot of things i don't i
have a trade-off i did there's not a
there's there's a maybe a lesser evil or
maybe they both suck but this is this is
going to suck less there's a lot of that
in life so a lot of times i and it's
okay not to have the answers here's the
thing b if you would have said i have
all the answers you're a narcissist yes
it's human to go i don't know but also
going through therapy more and more is
making me a better dad
you know what i'm saying like that that
everything i do better dad you know what
i'm saying like the way i talk to my son
about certain things he's having a bully
issue at school you know the way i came
up i was like
because
if it gets to me it's a problem
my girl in that school knows i'm busy if
it gets to me it's come at a level where
all right we've tried everything it's
it's a problem
it got to me
dude the aggre the
anger that i had in my heart when i
found out my son was having issues is
some of the worst anger i've ever had in
my life i called my therapist on the
spot you know i talked to you right now
she's like calm down don't send an email
i want you to call him because she knows
your emails can be brutal dude yeah
so i did i went and she said i want you
to wait an hour
think through it wait an hour and i
called him great advice [ __ ] great
advice man because when i told my son
how long has been going he's like you
know it's been you know four months and
your heart starts playing right away and
and and he's doing this to the other
kids and but what has he done you know
he's hit me and i go and tiger he's the
most you know it is what is he most
athletic he's big for six year old and i
go and he keeps doing it t and you tell
the teachers yeah and i go and you and
is the parents are wherever he goes yeah
mom's aware of it i looked at my girl
why wouldn't you tell me she goes
because i know you overreact i'm not
going to overreact so my initial and i'm
sure parents have gone through this
that's why i'm
telling the story my initial reaction
was i got bullied in fourth and fifth
grade
my dad goes how long has been going on i
go about two weeks now it's every day he
goes it's not going to stop till you
stick up for yourself next time he does
something i don't care if he's in
trouble you take your [ __ ] fish you
punch him right in the face
you answer back and he's going to stop
because he knows
you're not the one
that's what i told my son
here's i said his thing dude you tried
it all i go did you talk to him he goes
yep you talk to your teachers yep so you
talk to the parent she goes yep and he
keeps doing us yep i said tomorrow when
he does that and my son starts crying i
don't want to hit him i don't i go you
have to do this if he tries this
tomorrow you got to let him know you're
not the one
because his school's k-12 i said bubba
take it from me i'm too nice i get taken
advantage of all the time all the time
you know this all the time because i'm
so nice i told him i said you're gonna
deal with this for the rest of your life
dude you [ __ ] hit that kid
and he knows you're not the one
now
it might be me projecting my own issues
on my son you know
and he's crying because he doesn't want
to hit him stuff like that i walked away
and i felt like a complete piece of [ __ ]
like i mean hittings can't be the answer
it's not there's no way that's the
answer not the answer it's not the
answer
i i i like the one thing i want to do is
a meal plan i don't have time to cook
all the time so what happens is i go a
long period without food that i gorge
and i need i need i love because i
travel i'm in my car all the time i want
my meals with me dude you need factor
factor makes it easy for a thick boy
like myself to eat clean 24 7. really
with fresh it's never frozen prepared
meals that are delicious you wouldn't
believe they're this good dude because
you're losing weight you get in shape
you're looking good man all right feel
good for the summertime they have keto
options dude calorie smart keto options
built in portion control they're going
to do it all so it takes the guesswork
out of it factor now offers 30 meals per
week you can choose from a variety of
new meals every single week so you never
get sick and you change it up though
yeah you can change it up so i don't
have to whatever you want man whatever
you want add two three or even four
meals to your order whatever you like
most factors save me time by delivering
chef crafted meals to my doorstep dude
no grocery stores no dishes none of that
stuff just results your boy looks good
i'm wearing short shorts right now
thanks to fat ready to eat in two
minutes apparently yeah dude head to
go.factor75.com
fighter120 use the code fighter120 to
get 120 buckaroos off this delicious
meal plan that's code fighter120 at
go.factor75.com
fighter 120 for 120 buck ruse off your
meal plan they offer vegan veggie meals
keto meals low calorie options cold
press juices smoothies energy bites
plant-based bars extra protein edgy
sides dude damn there's no reason to be
out of shape man stay tuned focus.75.com
fighter120 i want i want to stay
optimized at the end of the day if
you're not optimizing your body you're
getting in the way of your success i
think if most people felt really good
the world would be a better place
physically if you felt really good you
know if we had to send our haters some
audit supplements that's all you need to
turn from haters appreciate it
because you got to feel good dude yeah
you get
alpha brain focuses your brain total gut
health it all starts in the get down
that saved me from i had one month i
know this for a fact i had one month of
i ate bad sushi for one month i wasn't
right i took
uh i took total gut health i think five
times and it went away i stay on it
whenever daddy has a little tummy
problem total gut health bad they got
protein powders they got protein bars
protein bites they got uh freaking dark
roast coffee elk bars warrior bars fat
butters we got it all man work out gear
we have on demand workouts streaming
fitness you don't have to go to the gym
anymore steel clubs
on it sandbags battle robes yeah you
want a great workout get on it stand
back get a baller up you're doing worse
and then do the audit in 30. yeah dude
kettle bells promo bells legend bells on
it.com fighter 10 off on it.com slash
fighter 10 off it's so hard too because
that that is such a natural reaction of
being a protector and being a man and
all that [ __ ] it's so deep in our dna
and and i love people who are like oh
hitting's not the answer but you're
doing it in another way you know human
beings like don't tell me that yeah yeah
i know yeah hitting is not the answer
that's probably bad advice to your child
right um it depends though right well
i don't know an inconvenient
conversation because what happens is
people will do it in other ways they'll
destroy your reputation they're you know
both sides there's social violence my
joke on that like like the a
right-winger will punch you in the face
if you insult the country a left-winger
doesn't believe in violence but they
will publicly shame you and destroy your
career so which i'd rather you punch me
yeah you tell me what the [ __ ] so both
sides believe in destruction don't tell
me i would say one's worse than the
other yeah well getting punched in the
face isn't that bad yeah trust me at
least you're standing there and you're
[ __ ] up close and personal but then
it's over right it's not a constant
barrage right of abuse online and both
both are not probably they're the the
question is and i don't have an answer
again i don't have an answer for it for
yourself doesn't say what do you do no
now it's stopped you know i had a
conversation with the parents out of
conversation with the teachers talk to
the parents i talked to you guys come
together
and the parents have to meet you halfway
and if not like i think now now parents
get together teachers get together we
figure something out you know what for
me what i what i
would do in my experience is parents get
together the kids get together with the
parents
we have a common thing you create a
common enemy maybe that they have to
they have to team up together and work
together they have an experience
together but it's tough look and the
other day too dominance hierarchies
exist no matter what and you are going
to have kids that have new weaponry they
feel strong and they're going to use it
my problem is that bad apples my problem
that's thing bad out because
as i talked to the other parents who was
on a group text every single parent had
to complain about this guy anti-social i
told the school i went yo
man yo man this just isn't one
circumstance
ask all these every single woman have a
problem every single one there's one
common denominator you guys have to do
something about this and then you know i
said if you don't do something i will i
know who the parents are i'm gonna drive
to school tomorrow i'll have a
conversation i promise you won't be as
fun as your conversation that's right
i'm telling you [ __ ] with my kid man see
what happens right i mean how long are
you going to do this you know i think
that the do nothing advice to you is
good for that
[ __ ] absolute [ __ ] so whether
it's a threat of violence and saying
drawing a boundary and saying do it
again and i will punch you i think
that's a very fair thing to say because
you're teaching kids like there are
lines you can cross well the world's
going to kick him in
the world's going to pop in the face if
that kid doesn't right
when you're dealing with a kid who has
all those other kids complaining guess
what he's doing he's also manipulating
and intimidating all of them to not say
anything correct you know so like have
you ever seen that you've ever seen like
uh in primates
so in chimp
uh colonies in bamboo colonies and stuff
they have baboon bamboo chimpanzee
baboon yeah yeah
what a male they'll usually be one male
one real sociopath male
that [ __ ]
beats up or kills
the children the females the the other
males the beta males and the whole troop
is awful and then then then a couple of
younger males will kind of start
emulating that and so a small band of
males are running this whole group and
it's off of the tyranny and then what
happens in chimps
is a couple of
beta males who are brothers or have been
friends forever or even a bunch of
females get together and go you know
that's enough we're going to tear that
fucker's face off yeah cool and they
kill that [ __ ]
you no it's not dude yeah it's crazy you
brought this up because my son's friends
ripped that kid's face off
full circle yeah you don't have a face
yeah because we're all the lady that got
all the monkeys ripped off by the ape on
oprah right he went like that yeah he
looks like that now did you learn your
lessons learned your lesson
you know
that's that's primary that's chimpanzee
no it is yeah the the book by franz
dewalt um
it's amazing these stories it's like you
can follow this whole narrative of how
these like the group the coalition got
together and said enough's enough and
overthrew this guy but then they're
dealing with their like it's apology i
think it was sapolsky who wrote behave
he had a ted talk about that and he said
baboons this one baboon came into the
troop and he was just uh there were a
bunch of baboons who were like you know
a bunch of guys like you and you and
just big kind of guys who were there for
a long time nice guys everything's good
and some [ __ ] greens kind of youngest
baboon comes in and he's like this he's
just walking around grabbing the females
just pushing kind of bullying grabbing
the other males right and kevin spacey
of baboon and he supposedly some of
those the males just sat there and all
of a sudden they just got quiet they
just got quiet
they just sat there like this right and
they're just looking and the next
morning all they found of that baboon
was its face yeah yeah like it's the
most gay has it it's like a ted talk
it's face it and his face is like this
they wait for the sun to come down like
squid games they rip that [ __ ]
off that was all that was left they were
like we're gonna [ __ ] good for them yeah
that's the way nature deals with we're
gonna scatter your body all over this
[ __ ] [ __ ] savannah oh that's
nature that's nature nature will but the
real world if you're if you are an
anti-social child okay this is the
literature on this is so clear i've read
about it i've read about it
that if you are an anti-social child and
you are doing things that make um people
not like you that does not get better
those kids end up in jail they get up j
dead
jail screaming shooters yeah all that
[ __ ] so it's it doesn't work out for you
no so that's the answer
kid's got to learn that kid who's a
problem has got to learn that the world
is going to punch you in the [ __ ]
face and it's going to be way worse than
tiger hitting him in the face it's going
to be jail juvie
all that [ __ ]
did you ever meet a sociopathic kid like
a younger kid where you're like oh
it's going to be a problem i have once
yeah i have once yeah and that is
psychotic children that exists yeah it
it you know if i met a kid who maybe
looked into it because i'm like
something's wrong with this kid and
nobody's acknowledging it and his mom
also thinks that never like never saying
no is a good parenting philosophy and
this kid has some weird behaviors well
this kid what grade mark i want to say
he was like nine but he would like
touch women like my girl he'd like like
touch girls related to yeah and it's
like so he's inappropriately touching
he's stealing [ __ ] he lies he'll do like
emotional displays and then back out
like i'm crying and then like you're
like no you're not and he's like i know
you just manipulated correctly
i
some of these kids will exhibit that
behavior toward their siblings right so
this one woman who had a son who was a
major problem never got better and uh
he
she knew
he threatened he said she heard him
saying to his brother he said it's okay
mom's not going to be here for a sec and
when when that happens i'm going to show
you i'm going to show you what you did
wrong and you're not going to be around
how old is he she was he was six or
something interesting
and she said she said she knew
because he had been exhibited that he
was in this tension he had never he
could he wouldn't connect with humans so
he would not connect with you
can you imagine his opinion the worst
also the the drawings that he was making
were
like the ring drawings beyond what you
can imagine horrible so when you have
when you draw a figure a human figure
um in school and everybody puts their
thing up he would draw
something so dark with teeth and like
horrible yeah and so they knew and then
he went to a school what do you do so so
there are schools there are schools
there are
things where where the child is
basically because so so sometimes a
child can you not change them sometimes
a child will kill their own sibling
you can have a ten-year-old who kills
his brother or sister
and does it
because the kid is and doesn't get
better it doesn't give [ __ ] it's like
pack mentality jesus and those children
now they put them in these
programs where they are there with other
kids like that
and that's they don't know what to do
with those kind of yeah is there a
teacher professor x like what do you do
yeah
so one thing about sociopaths is they're
concerned with themselves nothing else
right but and it's the way they treat
animals too right like the way they
treat animals if they're really
aggressive so that's different so so
there are sadistic sociopaths so that
would be serial killers who get off on
the act of killing that's a very rare
kind of aberration that that's a sick
dog that needs to be killed
but sociopaths actually tend to be
completely
um
apathetic to your just people they just
they're not interested in you at all
they're not interested in people they
never asked like how are you doing how's
it going none of that exists so what
what so they're just not remotely in
fact they'll they'll copy emotions and
they'll try to because they think
they're supposed to they'll mimic
empathy but so what you teach i don't
know anybody like that no no no it's
very rare
and it's really vanishing there with
with females yeah they exist but it's
way more common i met one of them yeah
wouldn't it yeah
yes
now now what's interesting about that is
is that what they'll teach a sociopath
is
you
can get it you care about yourself this
technique you're doing this this thing
you're doing is going to you're going to
get found out and you're going to you're
going to have it's going to be the worst
thing for you like amber for you
yeah they use examples of how you're
going to get found out no matter who you
are
this is the word so you have to you have
to kind of mimic you have to be
approximate a good person and do good
things and don't steal don't kill don't
do these things because it gets you
ahead because um you you can't get away
with it yeah and you make it you make it
very rational calculated and
mathematical yeah so that then that kind
of person says i'm going to be the ceo
of a company i'm going to give a
shitload of charity so my name is up on
a [ __ ] board so i have more money
more women more booze more everything
like yeah you're hillary clinton yeah
now the associate path a lot of times
though will a lot of ceos a lot of they
say chefs ceos surgeons knew some keep
calling people
politics
keep going they will tend to
put themselves in positions where the
only way they know how to relate is
power dynamics they have to be over you
yes they have to they can't ever do this
they have to be here everything is
strong versus weak
what a miserable [ __ ] life it doesn't
work have you uh that show uh love on
the spectrum yeah so the first season
which was [ __ ] brilliant you know
what this is yeah so love on the
spectrum the first season was in
australia some and these you realize
kids who have autism on the spectrum
some way worse than others
and you you know they're always
constantly looking for love they're
trying to make a connection the new
season just drops in america the
characters aren't as good the the the
individuals aren't as good as the
australian one but they're they're the
same right and there's a guy on there
who lives in san francisco he's 61 years
old he's never had a girlfriend and he's
on he's on the spectrum it's bad he has
a caretaker and he he looks he's older
gentlemen but he's looking for love and
they set them up on these dates but i
told my girl mike i would
i wish i had a friend like that he sees
his friend it's his best friend he's
like what are you looking for he's like
i'm looking for you but girl version
he's like you're so nice to me and just
the way he taught he's so proper he's
like it's good to see you how are you
doing and he's like you know the way you
make me feel after we meet we need to
see each other more because after i see
you
my day that's him right there steve 63
san francisco oh what a nice guy he
takes pictures because he went on a
dating app they set him up one date just
doesn't work the lady looks like the the
nun from the conjuring and then the
other lady that's so aggressive and then
the other lady has like pink dyed hair
but they're all on the spectrum
but this guy i'm like god i wish i had a
[ __ ] friend like this dude he's so
positive and just the the way he looks
at life is so positive then there's
another guy on there
who's really bad on the spectrum really
really bad but what about him wait was
it stop for him yeah why why why can't
he uh
what is it he just can't connect what is
it no he can't connect he's the most
loving guy you you've ever met the nice
guy in the world what's the problem he's
on the spectrum
like really bad so he's a caretaker and
like oh so he can't work he has no money
he has no he must so i i i i need to
look more into him but his dad was in
hollywood i think his dad was like a big
agent a big producer because he grew up
in la and then moved to san francisco
and his place in san fran i know san
fran uncle pax is from san francisco
you've always been to san fran i know
san fran i look at his flat that he owns
and he has a caretaker full-time like oh
daddy had money
which is all good and you know but for
him wait where's his gloves he always
wears gloves no matter what he always
wears gloves he goes on these dates and
zelda these ideas for dates and he's
such a kind [ __ ] person you watch
that show and you watch these kids on
the spectrum and then there's there's
one girl on there um and she makes a
connection she makes a connection she's
on the spectrum badge she's like
uh not her
he's james is really really bad really
bit meaning his his spectrum
on the spectrum he it's bad where
like he goes with this girl and he's
just he's like so much and the girl has
autism too and she was like hey i just
want to be friends and he like breaks
his heart abby see the mom in the back
gorgeous lady for she's probably 60
in the back so she makes a connection
she gets a real boyfriend the mom is in
tears because she's like i can't believe
this happened for my daughter i looked
at my girlfriend i can't watch this
you should though it makes me no no it
should you should watch it though it
will because it gives you an insight and
a perspective
where
even though these kids are expecting so
many problems the way they view the
world is so much better than us it's so
much better and then that mom is crying
i looked at my girl i go can you imagine
no if your kids had this like just the
luck of the mom didn't do anything wrong
like they look at their all but when i
looked it up with autism
a lot of it is the parents even though
they're not autistic they have certain
things they do where when they have kids
the kids have autism there's certain
markers they can tell people yeah yeah
it's like give me a hundred people and
be like i can tell you what are you two
pairing up some autistic kids i i forget
i looked up and said they're they can
the kids really well i mean i honestly
associated like a lot of asperger's have
super high iq oh so so a lot of it's
just they they like parents are certain
yeah
things yeah like all right
there's something there and they they
can say you can look at the two parents
you go there's a good chance your kids
can have autism now there's some kids
with autism like i would say elon musk
is on the spectrum correct yes some are
working on a different level yeah which
they can still function
yeah peter thiel peter thiel 100
billionaire but yeah crank this up and
maybe you won't read social cues as well
but yeah maybe maybe they're not the
funniest outgoing guy
i had dinner with peter thiel like
he's so smart like it was a group of
large groups but i i realized how
[ __ ] dumb i was because i was
listening to him talk and he has a
perspective like like everything i say
comes from what i've read you know [ __ ]
somebody else said it me too then i put
it together
okay if you talk about podcasts and
comedy all day i'll talk you off all day
outside that one
i've heard and then you know this dude
was formulating original thoughts in
real time so impressive where i was like
i've never heard that in my life models
of the universe that seems to me to like
if if i meet a billion or a millionaire
someone super successful in whatever
lane entertainment celebrity whatever
artist actor whatever that doesn't
really impress me you know what
impressed me the most these days is a
good vocabulary
like if they're throwing around words
i'm like where can i get a book to
improve my vocabulary my dad is that way
where can i get my father is my father
is
you can't i told you my sister and i
were going through the dictionary trying
to find words he didn't know i don't
know and then he was so impressed so he
knew every word but that get this then
we were making up words i was creating
hybrids and my dad would go like this he
goes not a word he just couldn't get
hey but so like you know since he
studied latin and greek
that helps but like as far as vocabulary
i thought because you know this 10 years
ago when we were at scopa and your
pretty friends and their vocabulary in
the in the politics i was like oh i'm a
meat head yeah since that day i read
your boy reads books
i power through books and i thought it
would give me a better vocabulary you
said that you go dude i'm embarrassed it
clicked i'm telling you there's certain
moments in your life
and i was you were all quiet no more
dude because that's on me
that's on me dude that's on me and
what's what's great about education for
anybody listening it belongs to you too
it's not hard you just got to read the
right stuff
you just gotta find something
interesting it's just information you
name a book on jfk
serial killers your boy gots it
history too love history love it world
war ii yeah one time about nazis i'm
dude i have my bachelor's steroids yeah
steroids for him but it's like if you
can find something that you're into in
the written so i thought by reading all
these books my vocabulary would get
better
it may be a tad but not really i wonder
if there's some way to do it there's
some website called membean that my
buddy did where it's like literally
there's websites where like every day
you can spend 10 minutes and it like
helps you learn more vocab really he's a
writer and he said it really helped him
because like you find yourself using the
same words over and over again and it's
like man to describe certain things i'm
like dude you're using that word too
much but it will also help in your
comedy yeah right
with you like i want to expand my
vocabulary for my comedy you know yeah
membean.com is one and there's probably
other competitors
will
a lot of it's reading good literature
good literature um is that those people
are masters with their words
read joseph conrad [ __ ] jose conrad
lord jim won't consider one of the
greatest
novels ever written he'll use words that
the the british
used words the way the [ __ ] italians
make cars i mean
this is the thing like you ever talk to
a brit like you'll make another accent
they go hey [ __ ] we started
oh no you're saying it wrong like no no
we started the english language you're
saying it wrong oh that's right correct
the way you say it is the proper way
exactly
exactly leaving with my kid like
you know my dad always told me education
education but you know
sports was a double-edged sword because
you can get by in life in your
major silver spoons yeah it's a bomber
dude so with my kid it's a bummer it's
not it's led me here but like with my
kids my dad always prided on education
like always first like yeah made sure
yeah very educated that's very smart
very smart you know arguing with him
he's insanely articulate yeah it's nuts
so and my mom wicked
[Music]
[Applause]
ton yeah and then i jus i just got to
the game late because i was majored in
sports but with my kids i tell tiger
because again him and boston
they're big athletic kids i'm like
that's cool man and that's fine and you
know that's gonna get you this far in
life i said but nothing is more powerful
than [ __ ] knowledge dude
and i go t that's on you bubba that's on
youtube so you know now you know we'll
still go to the toy story but we go to
barnes noble he gets a new book every
two weeks new book and he's reading it
and i'm like i'm telling you dude this
is power the greatest truth i i i go
dude you want to be you want to get far
in life the knowledge that you get dude
all this reading that you're going to do
this is power so even like at night you
can watch tv for an hour before he goes
bad he has a tv in his room which i
frowned upon but his mom wanted it
didn't want to fight about it so he has
a tv
so he'll watch like you know cartoons or
whatever and then i think it's on uh uh
apple tv they have a new uh show on
there on dinosaurs and technology is so
good these dinosaurs look
so [ __ ] real but it's educating him
on dinosaurs so he's brushing his teeth
i click on it and so when he comes he
walks in brushy teeth he goes papa i'm
ready i put on his you know jammies or
whatever and i go dude look at these
dinosaurs he's like that that was real
like yeah dude that t-rex was real man
and then you go to another one you guys
hold that that [ __ ] pterodactyl was
where i'm like those were real back in
the day he's like whoa i'm like tea you
know what's cool dude if you watch this
how cool is this he's like this is crazy
it's crazy you watch this and you and
you're going to download all this
information you know how many [ __ ]
your friends will be jealous dude he's
like graham like yeah dude because you
know all this [ __ ] man and this is real
stuff d sonic the hedgehog and spongebob
that's [ __ ] you're wasting your time
that's what they let those kids do that
this stuff though dude this is cool well
don't now don't sleep every night yeah
every night he binge watches it it's 10
i think 10 seconds don't sleep on on the
power of fiction don't sleep in the
power of story no power storytelling
no it teaches you values yes so a lot of
great stories like spongebob that
teaches you value system my my ex sent
me a video she kind of cried around and
my son was reading on his own
he's 10 years old reading a book like
without pictures on his own i was like
that's [ __ ] this that that's
incredible i love it and especially like
my daughter at 14 and i don't say this
lightly it's possible that she's read
she's smart almost as much as i have i
know she's it's insane mm-hmm she's
right cool oh it's on she's read the
entire j.r tolkien series she's read the
entire
jk rowling that's that stuff she's like
what she's read the outsiders animal
farm orwell she's read it all read it
like and understands it it's [ __ ]
it's like this daddy's dad i was talking
about jiu-jitsu his son's big and he's
he goes you ever seen ferdiland i go the
big bull who's like loves flowers and
doesn't want to fight he goes yeah i go
that's me in the ufc he goes dude that's
my son and i go what's he in he goes i
have to force him to come to jitsu he's
the biggest kid he's a huge dude he's
the undertaker he's so big and i go he's
[ __ ] massive dude he goes i know he's
too nice dude i'm trying to i have to
drag him here and what's he like to do
he just loves to read and i went oh [ __ ]
i'm jealous man he's what i go he loves
rigos oh dude he read all the harry
potter novels he's 10. he's read all the
harry potters and i go dude
that is a gift huge gift i go that's
such a gift huge gift he's going to
dominate school man and if he does want
to play sports his size all good but man
he's into that my daughter understands
stories so well you can't watch a movie
with her i'm telling you like to the
point where she's watching a movie
and she goes she goes uh oh i got what
she goes that guy's about to get killed
i go what
no he's not she's like watching a
football game with tony
spear right through his chest i think it
was uh [ __ ] whatever that end game or
something she was like how about you
know she goes because she went through
the whole process she's seen story so
often that she knows maybe she should be
a producer right 100 percent which
should be 100 or an author it's
unbelievable i helped her with an
audition yesterday oh she's trying to
get into yeah so she's going to theater
cancer she actually let me help her with
an audition it was
awesome
and so i kind of got a sense because you
know it's like i know a couple of stuff
yeah a couple things and she's your dad
like even tony hopkins
tony hawk goes my son who's big time
skater he goes i came home my son and
his friends were watching these videos
and he goes oh what are you guys
watching and he goes come on dad just
get out of here he's like nobody he's
like we're trying to learn this move and
tony looks like
oh oh i did that like 15 years ago and
they go you dating us
yeah man i'm tony hawk tony hawk it's
crazy they just it's dad you know it's
dad
it's dad yeah like i literally was like
i can help you with that musical she
goes you don't know anything about you
know and i went
am i no more than your teacher yeah all
right
yeah you don't want to flex them too
hard with that stuff no it would just i
didn't say it i had to just be like like
dad would the coach says do this i'm
like yeah i know but you you don't flex
into it just show up in your gee one day
it's like you see what happens you
realize i know you said dude this is my
life i'm going to show you how it's my
job it was my job for many years i made
money doing this bubba literally it was
like my career choice man you know well
he had uh someone uh someone at his
uncle
i go how would you do against that guy
and and we're walking and like brendan's
face is right here i was like what the
[ __ ] like like i go how do you think he
would do against anything and just
before he even said his face his heroes
were walking i imagine pretty well brian
because i got paid to fight and he's
never gotten paid a dime i'd imagine
pretty well what do you think
who was it
like a random guy yeah great guy but
not total rando on that level
yeah i love when it's the best when your
kids get into the same [ __ ] you're into
and they don't know like my son my his
uncle is showing bottom of a lacrosse
stick
and he goes dad grandpa said you're
pretty good at lecrossal
pretty good
you know pretty yeah yeah yeah yeah dude
yeah i was all stabbed bubba yeah yeah
played yeah you're number one the nation
buddy he's like what i'm like yeah
he's like what is there any video i'm
like i don't think so no a couple things
yeah my kids you know i love your boy
you played pro uh
lacrosse with or whatever you played
luke gilbert tall guy six six handsome
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] freak he works
for like nascar sponsorships stud
athletes right smart smart kid dude yeah
oh stupid lacrosse [ __ ] he was good six
six he came from um umbc which is
university of maryland baltimore county
which on the east coast is taller than
six six he's six six six seven maybe a
handsome bastard yeah tall lanky dude he
was so good at lacrosse he was like
unstoppable he's an attacker that's not
him and that was not can you imagine if
that was him yeah oh no you're still on
love on the spectrum
that's him right there on virgil that's
him right there luke gilbert which one
that's him uh on the suit in front of
the building yeah this one yeah that's
him right there yeah great guy great
[ __ ] guy san diego seals everybody's
six seven yeah
and axe and everything he was the best
yeah right he's my roommate yeah
whittier loves you oh he was good at
lacrosse oh my god he was ridiculous but
he he was a guy who it was at umbc
university of maryland baltimore county
where on the east coast la crosse's
bible i mean they're [ __ ]
good man so he grew up in that culture
in maryland coming up in la crosse
and then he was like hold on i can leave
here even though it's division one and
go to
whittier in california you know they'll
get they you know at that their
scholarships they'll figure it out he's
like but i can play in california and be
a superstar dude well so it's so good i
grew up watching tennis with guys who
played tennis were roughly my size maybe
a little bigger some of them were six
two and some of them were you know
mcenroe was and borg were 165 pounds
right
and now
tennis is attracting guys who are six
seven like that big boys who are crazy
after big boys yeah yeah and and in
russia and all over the world and the
way they hit like the speed of powers
is a literally a different sport
everybody had to change their stroke the
game just changed there's no it's like
you can't but when i was coming playing
lacrosse like i started my freshman year
right made varsity playing my freshman
year first time made varsity got
lettered four-year letterman but
playing lacrosse in colorado it was just
starting to get big in colorado yeah
it must be what it's like for like
white guys in the 60s when you're just
playing against other white guys and
then black guys start coming in you're
like holy [ __ ] he just dunked put his
nuts on my face he dunked from the free
throw line you know what i'm saying so i
was playing against other white colorado
players and then when i got to college
and you're playing with guys in new york
maryland boston where they've been
playing since they were four whole
different it must be like being a white
guy in the nba and then black guys are
coming like
oh my god you oh no no i'm done so i
can't play it i can't compete my buddy
finn played for the cardinals he was a
professional baseball player back
when it was
he goes before the latin's gun vault he
goes and then the dominican the
dominicans came in yeah you talking
about the kid like
dude puerto rico
my buddy finn's a big guy
but he goes they were throwing bbs
they were throwing [ __ ] straight line
from from center field like he had never
seen lasers lasers he goes he is they
were the best athletes i'd ever seen in
my [ __ ] life i'd never seen that kind
of strength speed it was just literally
a different thing it's not sound like
this yesterday there there should be an
asterisk on the hall of fame
like if you were a white guy that played
in the six seasons
there should be an asterisk that's fair
hit the ball against other white guys
it's fair and then the threat there
should be another hall of fame that then
there was latins and they were there
outliers i'm sure jerry west would still
do really well today i mean he played
with some black guys but like pistol
pete or like
you know some of these straight up like
ty cobb
he wasn't hitting junk off a puerto
rican kid in the bronx yeah he's hitting
[ __ ] a curveball off jeff you know
what i'm saying like other white guys
there should be an asterisk well now now
the number of guy pitchers that pitch
100 miles an hour it used to be so
standard
it's so interesting man
all right tim what do you got
i got to pee jim's been quiet let's go
i'm nervous now while we're waiting it
is 12 10 p.m pacific
the johnny depp amber heard uh
verdict is due any second now they said
3 p.m eastern which is 12
l.a times i think she's so clearly lying
i'm just you know with the jury who
knows you never know what they're doing
you know what's interesting is the last
three nights this and i mean they're
talking about this on the news the last
three nights
clearly he's just taking a private jet
but uh johnny depp because he has to be
in dc for the trial
as soon as trial ends he takes a private
jet to england to london and he's been
on stage the past three nights wow with
the band playing playing on the band
so i'm assuming he because he has to be
in dc
yeah he has to sleep in the jet and come
back lands puts his scarves on mascara
and then [ __ ] goes to the courtroom
let's discard the mascara can i give you
a quick update a defamation lawsuit
between the two of them totaling over
150 million and the jury doesn't fill
out the amounts awarded to whomever is
found to be in favor like some paperwork
error happens so people like what the
[ __ ] like you know
but they should be announcing logistics
just do that afterwards let's know who's
guilty i know
[ __ ] come on
will you keep an eye on that mark yes
all right jim what do you got buddy all
right first one is from mark
and this i thought was crazy i think
chin catches everything with this is
from marcus
he did years cat would have joked
brendan sent us this
just say current events
you don't need to know who did it i've
not studied this though that's why
that's a market
mark
but we don't know who they came from
every time all right
this is from marcus it was just funny
because i'm like because the first i did
a few dark ones the first thing
this is this is what the rumor was and i
didn't buy it
where is it but is this real you know
who said it oliver stone and i trust him
because of his access to putin and
there's a lot of things that corroborate
like he may have already beaten this
cancer but like
there's there's they talked about it on
breaking points yesterday and i also
trust them as far as their journalistic
integrity for sure um
they were like
he's it's not like he has
potentially something it's like he's an
old dude first of all so like i think
he's already been through treatment
you know 70 something yeah and it's like
like there was some
issue like you can look at like he's got
this puffy face and maybe that's due to
pregnancy and then he had some marks on
his face right too yeah and so and he's
pulled out of these things so there's a
lot of corroborating evidence where
you're like yeah
filler
the story is an fsb officer described
the russian president's condition as a
severe a severe form of a rapidly
progressing cancer as speculation ramped
up that putin was suffering with some
form of serious illness says he has no
more than two to three years to live
that's what's scary because he's leaving
this earth and he wants to leave his
mark correct so is he gonna release
those nukes you know what i'm saying
that's what's good that's what is scary
and then you know biden's providing
ukraine with missiles which is a big
no-no with the nato
yeah
yeah
it's it's a
that mix of factors
is uh
worrying to say the least
but
yeah news of the russian leader's
terminal illness emerged as part of a
secret message from the russian agent to
fugitive and former fsb agent boris
karpichkov carpet whispers about boone's
health beyond at least two years ago
when he was said to be suffering from
both parkinson's and cancer
rough combo yeah it's tough
but just gotta hope that he's not like
right i'm out here in two years let's
release the nukes yeah but he is
thinking something right he is uh taking
drastic action like that with his legacy
in mind he had some that's why he's
invading ukraine right yeah yeah but you
just don't know what what what's the
extent to which he's willing to destroy
legacy yeah you ever seen his house dude
no
yes no i'm not
on the cribs yeah i didn't bring that up
yeah i wish it was on
because because they say he's like a bit
like mega billion like we don't know how
much money he has look at that [ __ ]
house dude it's a nice uh
oh now where is that that's indeed it's
in russia in the black sea or something
yeah i don't know yeah somewhere look at
that [ __ ] castle it's a castle yeah
it's a nice castle
apparently he has all the money in the
world
yeah he's got all natsos is that place
yeah he's doing pretty well for himself
he has wives and girlfriends
his hitting kids and [ __ ] sure yeah
red notice is a book that i'd recommend
anybody listening who wants to know more
about the
the specifics of the uh kleptocracy that
is russia like how does he funnel all
this money into whatever
oh with the oligarchs like all the
little guards yeah i really didn't have
a story yeah yeah and how he broke like
he took one of them and like he's like
oh you like this you like me in a cage
give me your half your money yeah the
rest of them the rest of the population
doesn't suffers and it's like well
can just have your property or your
business taken away from you yeah and by
some guy who's connected to the kremlin
yeah but let me ask you this so let's
say putin dies in two years who takes
over is there another [ __ ] yeah they
have people on them another [ __ ] oh
yeah but there's people in line you know
my father did business in russia in the
90s when the wall came down and there
was all this opportunity he did a lot of
business he was trying to do business
yeah
trying to
and you know what was happening you know
why he got the [ __ ] out and why every
american got out including some other
friends i have
the they would they were getting killed
the guys he went to have a meeting with
the guy got [ __ ] assassinated by
mafia kremlin kgb yeah because they
wouldn't agree to terms or whatever nice
just take your business yeah
it's like oh oh you're succeeding by
like bringing this hedge fund you know
into russia yeah too bad we don't like
that and then then
putin decided this was going to be a
disaster for foreign investment yeah so
he basically got the spetsnaz guys to
get into fans and they knew where all
these mafia guys were they were always
like you know they would they would just
be sitting there having tea they come
out of vans they kill all of them they
shot a bunch of them and it still didn't
work at that point it was like no no
this is so who you know i mean i heard
putin's not like he's not liked he's not
he's not like his approval rating and in
russia he's liked in russia he's a
strong man that russians always because
remember he did give the russian
stability prosperity to an extent in
comparison and in comparison to other
leaders other russian leaders of their
history he didn't kill a lot of people
he didn't he didn't like you know
not compared to that but it's also like
in his cabinet like the next guy up
i heard there's like huge disc that's
why putin always like meets with him on
like zoom and [ __ ] like that so i assume
maybe the next guy up isn't going to be
as much as a you run a business you run
a business you don't run a big business
you run a business and you put out a lot
of fires think about running a country
with all those
[ __ ] i can't imagine you i
can't imagine it's a constant thing and
he's always worried about getting
served and killed yeah
you know yeah
i would not want that gig no he maybe he
got i don't know anybody wants to be
president
it's a nightmare what else you got jen
all right here's another current event
mark yeah
oh yes yes yes i can open up that one oh
so i thought this was interesting given
our what we were talking about earlier
maya cohen's entre into the world of
obesity medicine came as a shock so
basically she was trying to get this
obesity medication and her doctors
wouldn't approve it
she saw the price her pharmacy was
charging 1500 bucks a month her insurer
classified it as a vanity drug and would
not cover it though
what's the obesity pill it's called
sexenda and it's basically
like it regulates appetite and like
insulin and like um like a glucagon like
you know like it's not it's not a it's
not a stimulant in other words it's it
regulates the actual hormone curbs your
appetite yeah
now let's just say you're like i don't
know 240 pounds pretty in good shape
yeah you took that
what happened
some of the uh the side effects you know
they always make it sound bad but it's
like
um
you know to make sure
sex end is safe for you tell your doctor
if you have stomach problems causing
slow digestion kidney liver disease high
triglycerides heart problems a history
those are things that you should know
beforehand side effects the side effects
i saw were like throwing up
you know nausea but again you don't know
what that what the percentage is like
they just become bulimic
when i had my psoriasis before i worked
with dan garner
who cured me [ __ ] when i had
psoriasis i there was a cream
that i does i don't need my insurance
and they go well you do because
it costs fifteen hundred dollars holy
[ __ ] and i was like what and and of
course then i got it for like twelve
dollars because you use good rx
good rx yeah and um but it worked um it
worked not at all not at all i really
didn't have creams that dermatologists
will give you creams they don't work you
can do humera you can do you can't get
life insurance on it you can do certain
biologics that like cure you real [ __ ]
but the creams didn't work for you no
yeah you're stressed that's a joke
remember that then it all went away fun
a lot of it yes
it's it's something that i only found
out about today but is this this a pill
that anybody can take who's overweight
it's an injection oh yeah so you just
don't get hungry
it regulates it you feel it makes you
feel full not me i'm not taking that
[ __ ]
an injection yeah mark said when you get
down the dark web
actually i'm going to
um because a lot of i mean like let's
just be honest a lot of this that you
buy yeah if there's a market for it the
only thing is like
if nobody's buying if there's not like a
you know if you can't make money off it
it's not people aren't selling it but if
there is then yeah
yeah if you're a bodybuilder or fighter
and you cut and wait and you take this
you're not hungry yeah because it's
nonstick everything else is kind of like
whether it's clan or caffeine or like
whatever stimulant
like
you your body gets used to it so quickly
it means it starts to so something like
this is an interesting thing to look
into oh yeah and maybe bring it to the
office and just kind of leave it
all right any updates on okay i'm gonna
do it one more time because it seems
like everybody's like they didn't fill
out the paperwork correctly
um me too for some weird reason
this is i think no matter what happens
johnny depp in the public guy is he won
yeah
unanimous verdict wait my sister making
me listen for it
okay it is unanimous verdict that's what
we know
and
so you know it has to be for this
goddamn we should just live stream it
um
livestream actually on your laptops yeah
they they they've reached a verdict but
they don't if they're going to announce
it when
i don't know the other one the other
current event we had was jada pinkett
smith what is it yeah
jada pinkett smith says she's finally
addressing the infamous oscars slap but
rather than apologizing she's saying
chris rock and will smith both have to
set aside their differences i love that
like fake like you guys but it's like
well do you have an opinion on this or
you're saying you guys need to get
obviously guilty of what dude yeah don't
hear it yeah here we go
[Music]
this is a really important red table
talk on alopecia considering what i've
been through with my own health and what
happened at the oscars
thousands have reached out to me with
their stories
i'm using this moment to give our
alopecia family an opportunity to talk
about what it's like to have this
condition
and to inform people about what alopecia
actually is now about oscar knight i
think she looks hot
she has all her follicles so i don't get
these two intelligent capable men have
an opportunity to heal talk this out
and reconcile the state of the world
today
we need them both and we all actually
need one another once you've said that
until then
one and i are continuing to do what we
have done for the last 28 years
and let's keep figuring out this thing
called life together thank you thank you
for listening what a waste of time
her hair looks like if she grew it out
it'd be super thick you see everything
there so when she says alopecia yeah
alopecia is like
you're missing oh johnny wood one yeah
one for the good guy really yes
wow
of course unanimous verdict they're
getting a lot of yeses right now
wow okay
well it's unanimous y'all you me
give me a shave
answer yes
question this statement has a defamatory
implication about mr depp answer yes
question the defamatory implication was
designed and intended by ms heard
answer yes
question due to circumstances
surrounding the publication of the
statement
it conveyed a defamatory implication
to someone who saw it other than mr depp
answer yes wow
do you find that mr depp has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that ms
heard acted with actual malice
answer yes
as to the statement appearing in the
op-ed entitled a transformative moment
for women it's a win for truth i'll say
that yeah this is the truth
ever heard i spoke up against sexual
violence and faced our culture's wrath
that has to change
in the washington post online edition
quote i had the rare vantage point of
seeing in real time how institutions
protect men accused of abuse
end quote
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
that question the statement was made or
published
answer yes this is all going on now
the statement was false
answer yes
question
implication about mr depp
answer yes
question the defamatory implication
was designed and intended by ms heard
answer yes
question due to circumstances
surrounding the publication of this
statement it conveyed a defamatory
implication
to someone who saw it other than mr
death
[ __ ] you guys
as against amber heard we the jury award
compensatory damages in the amount of 10
million dollars
as against amber heard
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of five
in civil case number cl 2019
2911
ms heard's claim against mr depp
one
as to this statement appearing in the
april 8 2020 online edition of the daily
mail
quote
amber heard and her friends in the media
use fake sexual violence allegations
as both a sword and shield depending on
their needs
they have selected some of her sexual
violence hoax facts as the sword
and flick inflicting them on the public
and mr deb
do you find that miss hurst has proven
all the elements of defamation
answer no
two
as to this statement appearing in the
april 27
2020 online edition of the daily mail
quote
quite simply this was an ambush a hoax
they set mr def up by calling the cops
but the first attempt did not do the
trick
the officers came to the penthouses
thoroughly searched and interviewed and
left after seeing no damage to face or
property
so amber and her friends spilled a
little wine and roughed the place up
got their story straight
yes has ms heard proven by a greater
weight of the evidence
that question mr waldman while acting as
an agent for mr death
made or published the statement answer
yes question the statement was about ms
heard answer yes
her career
she's an [ __ ]
she has no morals to do that did she say
this is so beautiful for me she's gonna
have to be an aquaman 15 to pay off
johnny depp one for the good guys one
for truth [ __ ] you
got the statement by mr walter keep
listening or shall we pause
[Music]
but she's saying this is for
her it's for her yes i don't get it in
the april 27
2020 online edition of the daily mail
quote
we've reached the beginning of the end
of miss heard's abuse hoax against
johnny depp end quote do you find that
ms heard has proven all the elements of
defamation
answer no
[Music]
as against john c depp ii we the jury
award compensatory damages in the amount
of two million dollars that's 17 minutes
the second
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of zero dollars okay
does either side wish to have the jury
pulled yes your honor all right jamie
members of the jury if this is your
verdict please answer yes
if this is not your verdict please
answer no
juror number six
[Music]
million verdict i guess is against depp
for that really specific thing
which is like so it's like
he gets 15 million she gets 2 million
ladies and gentlemen this concludes your
service in this case i want to thank you
again for your dedication and your hard
work during this trial i know i speak
for everybody here uh when i appreciate
tell you that we appreciate your
sacrifices and your time and your public
service in this matter okay so i'm going
to have you go back to the jury
deliberation room for one more uh time
and then we'll release you from there
okay all right thank you
holy [ __ ]
guaranteed she starts fake crying you
don't want a bet
well i don't know how fake you could be
that your whole life just got [ __ ]
destroyed you're 17 million dollars in
debt now 15. yeah well so i guess the 2
million was against
death
because there was some article where
they like claimed that she rough like
that was because they switched at some
point they're like 50 million and then
they're like okay in the counter suit
yeah but isn't she gonna have to pay for
all his lawyer fees too since she lost
probably it's a two million enjoy that
well no enjoy that enjoy that elon musk
at least yeah at least so you know at
this point she doesn't have that money
she's not like i said she didn't have to
make aquaman 17 just to pay john
like for real she might be thinking
about an only fans or finding a very
rich husband or you know there's got to
be something like having a kid with a
billionaire or something but you can
claim poverty you can claim like i don't
have that you just fought that seven
million dollars that you were going to
give to those people you're going to
have to give right over here johnny yeah
yeah
that you were definitely going to get
you know you're definitely going to give
that 7 million now you're you're eight
million dollars in debt or
[ __ ]
yeah one for the good guys wow people i
think and i think women and men for that
matter will women twice before they
start spreading
before you ruin somebody's life with an
accusation and when somebody can't
defend themselves you know yes it's like
and it's and if it's 22 years
later i guess you just got to eat all
the dicks and then you get a journalist
that's
you get a journalist that's just dying
to be you know to make a name for
themselves and they go to twitter or
they try to find people
and it's it's it is what it is it's
coming back around
what else you got jen
um shout out to johnny depp we're at two
hours how many you guys want can you go
is
white shark eating a seal but it's very
very bad the video i kind of do want
yeah so this is the very first one of
the season and this is in massachusetts
in nantucket that's nature and it's
annoying because the girls in the video
you'll see
can you hear me it's a seal swimming for
his life women are screaming about
nature
you can see the blood which is kind of
cool
you see that right
it's so wild i've been swimming at a
beach i've been swimming on that beach
many times back in the day
great white's everywhere it gets deep
right away would you go again though
after seeing this
i would never swim in the ocean never
again not with that [ __ ] mm-hmm
that was a terrible video i know i told
you it was gonna be terrible oh i
thought it was gonna be terrible
so this happened and people are so
stupid they get like
it's like play stupid games when stupid
yeah but people continue to do it yeah
continue to keep it get [ __ ] up let me
see this one but here's the thing this
is not the video of the actual gorings
so a woman got a double hanging out no
i'll show you so this is actually kind
of an entertaining video but so bison
gord a woman after she walked up to him
in yellowstone park which happens i
guess pretty frequently bisons are the
ones that are responsible for the most
super aggressive
but people keep wanting to get close and
taking pictures they're so stupid so
this is a previous one in 2020 and then
this girl plays dead after she gets
close to that watch
but you're so dumb god do me a favor
quit yelling you guys are so dumb for
being out there yeah jim gaffney bit
about playing dead when you're a bear
it's like who wrote that the bears like
oh play dead and wrap yourself in honey
but she made it out by playing dead yeah
get the [ __ ] out of there
don't do that with yeah but just leave
the buffalo
the bicycle didn't core her yeah she's
fine
no the other lady got gourd though
um yeah that literally got [ __ ] up
let's see a quick knockout this is
marius oh yeah this is a great puzzle
too he was like a strong man winner yeah
and uh yeah this guy's not he's not
trump either the guy he fought was like
30 something and nine yeah
there's a spot
oh
god get in there and he's so jacked all
natty yeah he went he went over the top
and then did the same thing looked like
he was gonna understand nasty [ __ ] i
wanted to bring up something we talked
about in yesterday's episode
mahmoud sebby is the guy i found out who
you're talking about
oh the guy
like tagged him they're like
from egypt oh did they did he hear about
it
yeah so his name is
yeah his physique is ridiculous yeah
there he is
yes super thin waves
than that you're like what the [ __ ]
yeah i used to i mean
egyptians do have some good genetics
handsome son of a [ __ ] yeah wow olympic
wrestler too yeah shred
abs his abs look better than that i
don't know that's weird look it's hard
to be watched out but you can like he's
gonna have insertions he's a broad chest
no he looks fantastic he looks thin
though yeah uh he's probably a 85
big guy he looked pretty big to me he
does not look like an 85 or every bit of
click on him at that point i'm guessing
one seven yeah he looks like
maybe 5 11
i don't know how much what he sucks down
to but you know rose wrestler is
concerned
he's just starting out
um
i wonder he looks like a woman what did
he wrestle at in college you know i mean
not not college yeah he's a 170 pounder
yeah yeah yeah there you go good call
yeah 175 brocco roman walks around
probably 200.
shout out to
mahmoud
yeah 511.
jack city yeah he's three in one oh his
nickname is prince of egypt wow great
name yeah
a million followers what happened
he's egyptian manchester united people
are an olympian yeah you gotta love him
i didn't expect that's what that's what
just walks around like that you're like
[ __ ] off he looks sweet yeah
oh yeah and i met that guy too at top
team he's another killer he's about to
fight for the bellator title that guy
the black dot on the left yeah
it's okay it's like the american top
team has got russians egyptians lebanese
you know uh everybody everybody
brazilians black americans keep naming
it
it's just the united nations in there
cool yeah he's jacked
by myself i can't do it like that
well i'm not going to hell yeah b
well we don't look like that but we're
going to but if you want to get a look
of the real thick boy here i'm in
portland next week next thursday friday
saturday portland that's the helium june
9th through 11th portland oregon come
get some then san francisco at the cobs
friday saturday only uh june 17th
through the 18th and then uh from there
if chin would just scroll down quit
eating uh scroll up because you missed
the uh the fort wayne indiana fort wayne
july 14th through the 16th san diego is
july 21st the 23rd then i end the trash
pan of summer tour whole new hour august
4th through the 6th in baltimore there
you go but philly you're up next week
baby come get some philly take us at
thickboy.com richmond virginia this
weekend uh this coming weekend friday
saturday funny bone omaha nebraska next
weekend june 10th and 11th friday
saturday come get some i am not doing
ontario i gotta take that off my uh
website we said that yesterday uh and uh
best of my youtube show is going to be
airing it looks like this friday
[ __ ] is friday on brian on
youtube the brian youtube channel yeah
that's right so come on over go get some
check portland see you next week we love
you guys
congrats johnny depp johnny
the fighters kid
[ __ ]
route